[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Nick Wright host of first
things first on Fox Sports One and host
of what's right with Nick Wright on
iTunes and YouTube is back give me your
level of confidence going into this
Super Bowl as opposed to other ones with
the Kansas City
Chiefs uh so that's a great question hi
Dan hi everybody I also need Paulie's
help with something before the shows
over and I need an apology from you but
we can do all answer your question first
uh I would say this is
probably the second most confident I've
been but what's odd about it is the most
confident I was was the one they lost
the one against Tampa because I I think
people forget what a dominant run that
team had been on that team had won seven
consecutive games to win the Super Bowl
the previous year and then was 14- one
when momes started he sat out in the
final week of that year when they were
defending their title and rolled through
the AFC playoffs and then just got
worked over in the Super Bowl I listen I
think if the Chiefs can Block San
Francisco that they can do real damage
to the defense and I think that the ners
haven't looked great in six weeks like
since the Ravens game they they haven't
had a one game where they looked
dominant the way they did during large
stretches of the Season uh and so I you
know I the Chiefs big free agent
acquisition Charles omu from San
Francisco Torres ACL in the AFC title
game so that's a big loss and you feel
badly for him but both these teams
pretty damn healthy and I feel like the
Chiefs are playing their best ball of
the Year while the ners have kind of
been up and down so to speak how much of
a concern was it or is it that they
didn't score in the second half against
the Ravens so I don't I was not
concerned at all by that and I don't
think that people fully understand the
game the chiefs were playing what in
that second half so let me just go back
a bit Mahomes has had in my opinion one
truly bad on him that losses on you
playoff moment the second half against
Cincinnati in the AFC title game two
years ago uh I know you and I argued
about the Super Bowl against Tampa I
don't put that on I don't think he even
though the numbers are terrible I don't
think he played terribly the second half
against Cincinnati he did since that
moment he has not thrown an interception
in the playoffs and after being sacked
on average about three times per game
he's been sacked five total times in six
playoff games the Chiefs haven't lost I
give that context for these reasons the
chief's defense was so dominant against
Baltimore that as long as they had a
10-point lead in the second half I do
not think momes is number one goal
number one goal was to score more points
I think the number one goal do not turn
the ball over and we won't lose and so I
do think there were plays to be made
that were maybe 6040 plays 7030 plays
that he did not he was like you know
what not putting the ball in Jeopardy
that if they had to go move the ball he
could have and I think that's evidenced
by the fact the one drive they had in
the second half where it was a one-score
game he hit the pass to mvs deep
downfield and so all Al here's the other
thing Baltimore's defense is great it's
to me far better than San Francisco's
and so if there was any defense that he
kind of built to slow down the Chiefs
that was the most surprising part of the
game was Baltimore has the perfect
roster to slow down Kelce and Kelsey
then instead had maybe the finest game
of his career All Things Considered and
so Baltimore did some really good things
but I think Kansas City was very
conservative with the two-score lead
this might be an obvious answer I asked
it to Jason Garrett yesterday if you're
the ners are you more concerned about
the chief's defense or Patrick
Mahomes well I don't think it's an
obvious answer because the Chiefs have
the best defense in the NFL and this is
why all year long when I was called a
homer when and I'll just get to it now I
mean when you you know excoriated me Dam
near yelled at me at it was so awkward
at dinner your son left me Dan and were
at dinner together and Dan's son
couldn't take it anymore Dan pointing
his finger at me and being like just
admit you won't say the truth about
Patrick Mahomes in the Super Bowls just
admit that you're a Chief's Homer did
all these things we in a fancy joint
nice I don't know if it happened that
way but I know it's good content here so
continue did your son did or did not
your son leave uh he didn't leave
because of our conversation well I mean
that's not what I've heard since then
but that's fine no he's married with a
child so he probably is leaving so are
you so am I and yet we fin
he a new he couldn't handle the fact
that you were yelling at me in this
members only establishment you took me
to um but where you forgot your coat
it's still there is it really it's still
there I don't know that I'm allowed to
go there without you you can you can go
you can go in and get you can go in and
get your coat yeah I left my coat um I
was so rattled by Dan Patrick just
dressing me down in front of people um
but the point I the reason that I was so
confident throughout the year about the
Chiefs was I was like well yeah they
they drop the ball a lot and they commit
a lot of dumb penalties that is true
it's
undeniable but they don't just have the
best defense of the momes era because
that's kind of a low bar yeah they were
in the argument for the best defense in
the whole league number two in yards
number two in points and they did it
without forcing turnovers they were 28th
in turnovers forced so they didn't even
have the turnover look and so I I think
they have a great defense and that is
going to be a big problem for Brock
perie but the person you fear the most
is Patrick because even if the game is
going exactly the way you hoped there is
the fear that unless they simply can't
block for him he will make magic happen
as he has in every playoff game of his
career we're talking to Nick Wright host
of first things first on Fox Sports One
and host of what's right with Nick
Wright on iTunes and
YouTube how do they lose this Super
Bowl mcaffrey G just gouges them and
that and the ners are able
to uh take advantage of the Chiefs
tackles that the the mcaffry listen the
Chiefs have the best pair of Corners in
football spagnolo is maybe the best
defensive coordinator football certainly
on the short list he's definitely the
number one coordinator draft pick
because unfortunately for him his head
coaching tenure went so bad no matter
how well he does he'll never get another
head coaching job so you don't have to
worry about him leaving like Mike
McDonald and Baltimore but that you know
Nikki Bosa is Nikki Bosa Chase young
decides this will be the game of month
he gives full effort for four quarters
and they beat up the tackles and listen
the ners are already pre complaining
they're already oh they hold a lot Jed
York what do you remember about the
Super Bowl oh an uncalled holding
penalty all this pre complaining I've
heard it all year long nobody wants to
know the facts nobody wants to know that
in these NFL playoffs two touchdowns
have been taken off the board due to
penalty they're both Chiefs touchdowns
on nonsense fake holding penalties
nobody wants to hear the facts that the
Chiefs this year had the second fewest
penalties called on their opponents
everybody is mad about a Super Bowl
holding call because love Fox we showed
a bad angle on the first on the first Go
Round And then after the game the guy
who did the hold was like yeah I held
and people are still like ah the fix is
in it's all nonsense so I get that
they're trying to Prime the officials
prematurely I understand these are the
things you do when you're trying to you
know stop a dynasty which is what this
is of course a dynasty I love your OB
objectivity uh well it's just the facts
Patrick mahomes's dad says that uh his
coaching or his quarterback uh whatever
Mount Rushmore he's got Brady and then
Joe Montana and then his
son well that's wrong you got Mahomes
over
Montana yeah and I my my my Mount so to
me one through four okay is Brady momes
Manning Montana that's my one through
four uh and then after that Marino Elway
Elway Marino you know is to me closer
than the Super Bowl you know Super Bowls
would argue and then and I I really to
be fair I as the audience knows I'm not
nearly as old as you so I didn't watch
you know I wasn't covering Johnny unitis
um but uh so I I really and I don't have
any recollection of Bradshaw so if we
kind of just go post starbo Bradshaw
Rogers Favre and then the guy who I
think gets really the short shrift is
Steve Young Who I think Steve Young is
one of the greatest players I've ever
seen didn't do it for quite long enough
but yeah I think I think Patrick Mahomes
is already the second greatest
quarterback ever I don't really think
it's that controversial of a statement
are you prepared for what the reaction
would be if Brock pie leads the ners to
the Super
Bowl well hold on and when am I am I
prepared for the react what the reaction
will be if the ners win sure yeah am I
prepared for what the reaction will be
for Brock py leading them to a win I'm
not prepared for the reaction I would
have if you spout sprouted wings and
flew far far away no I mean I don't I
don't spend a lot of time emotionally
preparing myself for things that aren't
going to happen but they could listen
the ners could win obviously uh you know
listen the Chiefs are The Underdogs for
the fifth time in their last six playoff
games there are nobody believes in US
team uh they you know they shouldn't
even be there I I watch smart people on
television going into the playoffs doing
a scariest AFC teams and the obviously
the Ravens were one because of their
great postseason history and obviously
the bills were too because of their
great postseason history and people can
say it's a straw man now but I you all
know you saw it you know who came in
third on a lot of those lists not the
Chiefs not even the Dolphins the
Cleveland Browns remember that Billa
Goods oh nobody wants to play Joe flacko
play off flacko in that defense we were
told that team was scarier than Patrick
Mahomes with the best defens in football
that's the nonsense that was pred all
year and then I just sat there and was
right and people called me a homer
because I happen to go to the parade and
you know what I mean I mean kind of be a
you know unofficial member of the team
but that's just a good
fortune can you believe that in 2015 the
commissioner was like you know we're not
into the gambling business you know it's
about the integrity and here we have the
Super Bowl in Vegas we have you know all
these sports franchises there you're
going to have an NBA expansion team in
Vegas LeBron LeBron just announced a
partnership with DraftKings yeah I mean
yeah I mean it's a Brave New World man
and this is what I'll say I am someone
who has gambled my entire life since I
was 10 years old playing pool with my
dad it is my my mom's
parents one of side of the family were
professional gamblers my dad for a
period of time was a gam professional
Gambler for you guys life strating
around it's in my blood I love
gambling I don't think it is this you
know Panacea to our country's you know
Financial ills you know as far as
funding local governments and I don't
think it's something that is necessarily
the greatest thing ever that it is this
easy and accessible but it is what it is
you know what I mean like it this is
where where the money is and the leagues
have dove in but yeah I I'm old enough
to remember was it Tony Romo who wasn't
allowed to like speak at a Fantasy
Football Conference in Vegas yeah A
lot's changed in the last decade the uh
load management the 65 games in the NBA
um curious your thoughts on this that
Tyrese halberton and Joe Ellen beid are
probably going to pay the price of not
being able to qualify but your thoughts
on the 65 or more for postseason Awards
Hart was in the right place the
unintended consequences might have bit
him here and I'm actually fine with
there being a hard threshold for League
MVP especially because if you look at
historically League MVPs up until a few
years ago basically all of them played
at least 70 you know and so the the
problem where it comes to me is we tied
halberton this is going to cost him $40
million we tied contracts to all NBA and
halton's not load managing he's just
been hurt and even with he's played so
well even if he with the injury he
played 62 games he was gonna be you know
at least third Team all NBA and that
makes his $200 million contract 240
million so I I I understand why they did
it I think maybe they took a
sledgehammer where you needed a scalpel
but I don't this is one of those things
I try not to criticize too much pardon
me because I don't have the answer like
I don't know it's not like oh here's
what they should have done but it it
seemed like they needed to do something
the thing they did I was like oh that
could work and now we're instantly
saying why maybe it doesn't work you
wanted something from Paulie yeah Paulie
this seems like something Paulie I mean
let's be honest he's the the man's man
of the show we know this um so I don't
know if you guys have heard it during
this interview but somewhere in my house
there is a smoke
detector that must be malfunctioning and
I spent the better part of two hours
yesterday going to every smoke detector
in the house replacing every battery
doing everything I can't Lo where it is
it is still going off and at this point
I think I have to move I don't know what
I'm going to do and I feel like Paulie
maybe is like oh here's what you do here
and so I need help because or else I'm
gonna go crazy uh I'm not an expert but
I would say close all the doors and go
room to room and try to hear it that way
so you drown out the bleed over room you
probably have either a CO2 detector or a
uh some type of uh smoke detector that's
hardwired and doesn't have a battery it
may be hardwired to an electric uh in in
your ceiling hard wired yeah and then
what do I do how do I fix that I'd move
if I were you you're not going fix uh
Sean you have something to end I
actually know exactly what it is
okay do you want to tell him I'm not
telling you though because I'm not a
man's man so I'll let Paul figure that
out though you guys you and Paul work
that out but good luck to you listen I'm
just judging based on social media
Paul's out there being wearing flannel
stuff and being like where's the best BR
worst today so I just assume this the
type of thing he would know about high
cholesterol doesn't mean I could fix a
fix a roof okay just hire electrician
it'll be a lot cheaper hire an
electrician for a smoke they're going to
laugh at me you know what a man's man
would be able to figure it out Nick wow
W that's listen I'm aware of what I'm
not my wife just heard your friend Dan
just heard this conversation she only
heard my end of it of course and she
just said not really that quietly just
cuz you're so stupid
like this
is this is not is not good and it's
driving me crazy so okay no I think you
may have you might be CO2 you it's
hardwired I think Paulie is correct I
had this in my house and of course I
figured it out and then uh I was able to
stop or it could be like a CO2 that's
Plugged In Low against like near a
baseboard you're looking up towards the
ceiling all right just for the record
before I go not to be that guy but I I
wasn't going to do it to Paulie but then
Dan it so I have to there are no CO2
detectors that's carbon dioxide it'd be
Co carbon monoxide the is for singular
yeah okay come on guys let's try to be
accurate on these things that's your
house yeah it is my well not for long
get out of here this is a disaster uh
Dan will you pick up my jacket for me
yeah okay thank you yeah at some point
over the next year I will get your your
jack that was a great place you took me
to I don't know if we can talk about it
yeah we can it was great yeah it was the
Italian Gun Club so so what they what we
did in the basement's legal
yes Dan took me to a
dinner first of all he shows up late so
I get in they're like hey do you have
membership I'm like yeah Dan Patrick
does so they let me in but Dan gives me
no information so I go to the bar and I
order a drink and I make a total fool of
myself because the guy gives me a drink
so I try to give him cash and he looks
at me like I got three heads like we
don't take money here what are you
talking about it's traded on names and
favors and things I'm like okay well I'm
already out of place then we've I asked
Dan I'm like how does the ordering work
and he's like we usually do one from
each course I'm like okay great so I
looked at the menu there were four
courses I ordered one of each the waiter
then looks at me like I'm crazy he's
like you want all of that and I look at
Dan he's like oh I didn't really mean
been three of the four so I'm now 0 for
two then the the manager comes over and
he's like do you want to go to the
basement and I'm like like I'm not
getting tricked again and I kind of
looked at and Dan's like yeah let's go
and but your son was excited about it
I'm like all right this might be a gag
but I don't know takes me downstairs
there's a shooting gallery we're down
there firing I've never fired a gun in
my life they're down there doing target
practice and then go upstairs and eat
yeah never see anything like it in my
life man left my jacket yeah and then
you yelled at me about the 2020 Super
Bowl why can't you admit momes is bad
here we go Nick Wright host of first
things first and host of what's right
with Nick W on iTunes and YouTube maybe
I'll see you in Vegas no I'm not going
oh okay not going all right sorry to
hear that that's why I'm on today and I
know we're long we could talk about it
another time yeah I'll talk to you after
the Super Bowl okay all right after the
Chiefs win that'll be great I'll call
you from the parade okay awesome I love
that yeah tell your wife I said hello I
will and we'll see you at the at the
wedding bye and I'll wait for my
invitation it's it's in the mail okay
goodbye all right all right we got to go
uh we're back after this